what is a wallet is it safe how can i
put bitcoin in a usb and carry it with
me if bitcoin fluctuates so much in
price how can i make sure that i'm not
paying for a pizza in bitcoin that later
that same amount of bitcoin will have
made me a millionaire okay so there's a
classic story about somebody who bought
bitcoin for whatever however many 120
bitcoin that at the time was very very
little now 120 bitcoin would be millions
of dollars so
it is uh in fact if i remember right it
might have been thousands of bitcoins
because the last time somebody checked
the pizza ended up costing like 250
million dollars or something like that
uh so
there is no way to know that and this
would be like buying something with gold
over time that gold is going to go up in
value
one hopes so you never know if that's
going to be the case so the way that i
would think about it is
personally i don't put money into
bitcoin because i plan to sell it i put
money into bitcoin because it's a store
of value and i want to hold it across
time and space so when i invest in
bitcoin i don't care about the ups and
downs of the market in the short term as
michael saylor said when it comes to
bitcoin any time horizon less than four
years is just noise now the reason that
he picked four years if i'm not mistaken
is because that's when it halves uh its
output
a i don't understand that well enough to
go into the like nitty gritty of how it
works but there are what are called
miners and they're currently mining for
that next bitcoin remember there will
only ever be 21 million units but not
all 21 million units have been created
yet and so there are miners that are out
there slowly creating this over time and
there's a set schedule at which
uh interval they come out and every four
years
the amount of time and energy basically
that it takes to release those unmined
bitcoins gets cut in half so if it were
16 per block now
at the next um four year cycle then it
will fall to eight and then four so on
and so forth uh so
that's why he says four years because
that ends up creating uh market dynamics
that change the price so a wallet as i
mentioned earlier
is a an application basically and the
one that i recommend it's the most
common when you're dealing with ethereum
is
meta mask so metamask is a chrome plugin
that is an extension on your browser so
you would search for metamask go to the
official site which will put the link to
the official site i'm pretty sure it's
metamask.io
but you're going to go there you're
going to
install it into your chrome browser
again i think that's the only browser
that it works for you get it in chrome
and now you set up your account you're
going to get something called a seed
phrase
whatever you're doing i want you to stop
and i want you to pay attention because
this is
the one of the most important things i'm
going to say
in the beginning remember i said part of
the thing that gets people excited about
the blockchain and cryptocurrency is
that it gives you sovereignty
when you take on bitcoin and hold it in
your metamask because maybe you bought
it in all cryptocurrencies by the way
let's say that you bought it on coinbase
they're the custodians of that
so there's a saying in cryptocurrency
not my keys not my coin meaning if you
don't have this seed phrase to be able
to
open and close
that the security on that to stop things
from flowing in and out then technically
coinbase or the government whoever the
government could come and put pressure
on coinbase to seize your assets whereas
if you have them in your metamask wallet
or you have them in a cold storage like
i mentioned earlier ledger ledger is a
usb drive that you can store your seed
phrase on now i haven't spent enough
time on hardware wallets to know the
exact mechanism by which it works but
it's basically a uh a dumb terminal that
can't be hacked it has so little
information and computing power that
there's virtually nothing is bulletproof
but there's virtually no way to get into
that thing so
uh
it's considered as unhackable as
something is going to get so by putting
your access to your crypto on x remember
your crypto isn't actually on that
that's your access to your crypto so the
thing that gives you universal global
worldwide access to your crypto is
something called the seed phrase now
when you create your metamask wallet it
will give you a seed phrase
when i say don't ever ever ever ever
under any circumstances for any reason
ever ever ever
don't ever give your seed phrase to
anybody else okay my wife doesn't know
my seed phrase now it's not because i
don't trust her it's because that's just
another point of vulnerability so
now you should be asking yourself though
but wait a second
if i'm the only one that knows my seed
phrase and something happens to me then
how would somebody else get my money or
like my wife upon my death or more
terrifyingly what happens if i lose my
seed phrase forget my seed phrase or i
get caught up in a phishing attack and i
give my seed phrase to somebody the
answer is you are
that's sovereignty
there is no recourse
if you lose your seed phrase
whatever that was protecting so if
that's your metamask wallet like right
now
in my metamask wallet i shudder to think
how much is in there
in nfts it's a lot a lot a lot
and if i forget my seed phrase or am
dumb enough to give my seed phrase to
somebody
and i do have empathy for people that
have been tricked into giving their seed
phrase which is why i'm really going out
of my way to say don't give your seed
phrase to anybody
if i forgot it or gave it to somebody
poof it's all gone
and you need to really think about that
but the great news is that nobody can
confiscate it so if you're the only one
that has it there's no way to get into
your metamask wallet there's no way to
hack that to get it out
and
that's doubly true if you have it on a
hardware wallet
so
you're trading
this inviolability
no one can take your money from you and
if you heard about what happened in
cyprus i forget how many years ago
but i don't know seven or eight ten
years ago something like that in cyprus
um
one day they just decided we're taking
10 of everybody's money to get the
government solvent again
now
you can't do that if you've got your
stuff stored on a hardware wallet
so
that's why people do that
but the problem is that
if you lose that seed phrase
there's no getting it back there's no
forgot my password that doesn't exist so
you have to be really really incredibly
thoughtful
about what you do with that
to circle back around to the pizza
question
the whole goal there is that by holding
your bitcoin it is going to go up in
value so if you're going to spend
like i said i spend ethereum and i hold
bitcoin but ethereum also goes up
and so that's a tricky beast and is
ethereum some people predict that
ethereum's going to be bigger than
bitcoin and that one day it's going to
be worth even more and if that ends up
being true you could be in the same
situation so part of how i get myself to
sleep on that one is that i just spend
ethereum so back and forth so casually
on things just like i would the us
dollar that it's like at some point your
money has to
function so if all you want to do is
hold then
use your us dollars for exchange
use your bitcoin ethereum as a means to
store value and just don't spend it
because no one i mean the whole hope is
that this goes up over time wanna be
happy build a life not just a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel is created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn how you can
use cryptocurrencies to their full
potential
enjoy
lesson number two buy crypto with raul
paul so
it was 2020 that march to june period
that made me reassess my big macro
framework
because
we knew what the central banks would do
but they did it harder and faster yep
and what we ended up with was the
shortest recession in all recorded
history and the biggest recession
that never happens
[Laughter]
so what we've done
is we've created a reaction function in
the central banks to do more because
janet and jay will look at each other
high five and go we nailed it
the world stopped
and we only had a two-month recession
and the markets recovered pretty quick
now we know that the reality of the
underlying economy and other things is
not so great but for the central banks
they're gonna do more of this why would
they not they're now thinking do we need
a business cycle at all
but what they're doing if you actually
look at it the central bank balance
sheets the g the big g4 central bank
balance sheets are growing at
about 15 a year
so i started thinking this through and
then thought
i know a lot of people use m2 as a way
of understanding printing but i just
thought i'm just going to use the
balance sheets because that's new stuff
that we know that they're doing and i
know that there's no
it's it's not a pure way of flowing into
the economy whatever but anyway
so i put the smp against the fed balance
sheet and all of us have observed that
correlation over time
and the thing was it kind of told us
what we deep down know is the s p has
kind of gone nowhere since 2008. it fell
in 2008 the money printing came and the
s p's basically been going sideways
and then i looked at gold and it kind of
had even underperformed the fred balance
sheet i looked at real estate it was
identical to the fed balance sheet yeah
i then looked at
the nasdaq and it had done better
because it had all these network stocks
in it and then i looked at bitcoin it
was like oh this is a whole different
world
so there's only one asset that looks
like it offset the printing of money
so if you know that
and you are able to trade it
then let's say we go into your quad 4
what are you gonna buy right well the
highest upside is gonna be crypto lesson
number three protect your purchasing
power with anthony pompliano you've
talked about bitcoin is going to become
the global reserve currency i don't
think
that governments go down without a fight
yeah so
global reserve currency uh first of all
is like a term that everyone talks about
but
what is a global reserve currency right
there's two ways to look at this one is
the legacy terminology of global reserve
currency which is the most dominant
military basically puts the uh the
currency you know in place and then
enforces that across the world the
dollar is probably a pretty good way to
use that as an example
every economy has a reserve asset
the us economy is based on the u.s
geographic
players right people within the u.s
geography
and the reserve asset is the u.s dollar
if you go to mexico
the mexican economy has a reserve asset
at the peso et cetera and you go through
the world this is true
there's an economy though that has been
created it's actually the largest
economy in the world and it doesn't have
a reserve assets the internet the
digital economy does not care about
where you physically are geography does
not matter it's unhinged from the
geography
what's the reserve asset of the digital
economy
well
most people would say well i use dollars
right that seems to be one of the more
popular ones
but that's because we live in the
developed western world
people on the internet in india don't
use dollars
right
they use their local currency and you go
around the world and you see this
what if we all just used one currency
and all the units were the same
okay that'd be interesting
and so
the reason why i say that it is going to
be a global reserve currency is i
actually don't think it's nearly as
competitive with the fiat currencies as
people think it is
because
ultimately what happens is
the digital store of value i want to
protect my assets
and so what we're moving towards is a
multi-currency world right right now you
and i live in a single currency world
you get paid in dollars saving dollars
invest in dollars and then you also pay
taxes in dollars if you want to go to
somebody else's single currency world
mexico you have to convert your dollars
to pesos to operate within the mexican
uh economy for the most part
well when you make that conversion it's
actually very difficult
you go to the bank and you try to
withdraw it's got to be large sums
or you go to like a currency exchanger
at the airport they rip you off right
like it sucks
what happens if all of a sudden the
friction and the cost of
transacting between currencies or
switching the switching cost goes to
zero
and now i get paid in dollars
and with a click of a button i can
change my dollars into pesos or into
bitcoin or into a digital euro et cetera
well now the technology is the exact
same the only difference the only
competition between the currencies is at
the monetary policy standpoint they're
all digital currencies so the digital
dollar digital peso and bitcoin are
literally all the same technology wise
in that steady state but there's
competition at the top layer
at the moment i mean at the monetary
policy layer what is monetary policy
all fiat currencies have the same
monetary policy
on a
structure standpoint inflationary
currencies okay meaning that there's
constantly more printed of it it's got a
variable monetary policy meaning that uh
it constantly changes sometimes they're
expanding sometimes they're contracting
but the reason why the dollar is
guaranteed to lose value is because they
have to continue to create more of it
right same with the peso same with the
euro et cetera
so if you actually take all the fiat
currencies and you put them in a bucket
there is a non-consensus or a different
currency structure which is bitcoin for
example and so if it ends up being right
it's gonna be wildly valuable it's not
consensus then right
but two is
if i'm looking to store value from i'm
trying to save
i'm not gonna save in the
fiat structure regardless of the
currency doesn't matter dollars euros
yen whatever
i'm gonna put it into an asset where it
protects my purchasing power
and if the switching cost is zero i know
i can switch back and forth very easily
so you can see a world where my employer
pays me in dollars it auto converts into
bitcoin i sit it there and then i gotta
pay my taxes in dollars i convert back
into dollars and i pay
well i'm saving in bitcoin i'm storing
value in bitcoin what do people do
well historically maybe i had to buy
real estate to do that so my employer
paid me in dollars took the dollars i
converted it into real estate i sat
there and then all of a sudden i needed
money to pay my taxes i could sell the
real estate get it and pay it back now
that's a ridiculous
you know order of events if i'm simply
going to use it as a saving mechanism to
then pay my taxes you know later this
year
because there's
cost there's time lapse et cetera
but there's no difference between doing
that with real estate or doing it with
bitcoin
it's just now all of a sudden i can do
it instantaneously i can do it with a
digital asset that protects my
purchasing power and the switching cost
is zero essentially
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there lesson number four borrow against
your assets with michael saylor if i
have
ten thousand dollars
i'm probably gonna hold fifty dollars
in my currency wallet i'm gonna convert
the other
9950 into bitcoin
because
that's my checking account versus
savings account
and even then you know the best thing i
think
the ideal situation you want to get to
of all eventually is
i put 100 of my assets into bitcoin
and then i have a credit card slash
credit line which is drawn
against the which is converted into
local currency
and it is drawn against the bitcoin so i
have 10 000 of bitcoin and i want to
spend 37
so
i spent 37 and now i owe 37
against
my quarter my 50 million satoshis
and i and i never really sell my bitcoin
i just generated debt against the
bitcoin
and this is
we're a little bit early here but
but if
if your expense ratio
is less than your expected appreciation
over time
that is to say if you expect bitcoin to
go up
10 a year
and if you have
a million dollars in assets and your
expenses a year 50 000 so your expense
ratio is 5 a year
and you expect bitcoin to appreciate it
10 a year if your expense ratio is less
than your expected appreciation over
time
you never have to sell anything ever you
can borrow against your assets from now
to the end of eternity
now it requires that you have uh a
bitcoin banking sector developed right
you have to have a credit line against
the bitcoin and we see that developing
in different ways around the world but
but ultimately that would be the ideal
situation you would want to have a you
would want to have a situation where
you're holding bitcoin and you're
drawing credit lines in the currencies
that exist lesson number five be your
own banker with mark cuban here's what
it comes down to either the applications
are going to be there to make life
better
and to make business more productive
efficient and profitable or they're not
and that is everything right there and
so if it's easier to transmit value from
point a to point b
using bitcoin
or using ethereum or using somebody else
all right that's what we're going to do
because the way swift is set up right
now for for you know international
transfers is ridiculous
and you know like
like jeff bezos says your margin is my
opportunity
it's the same here you know the
banking's margin the bank's margin
is bitcoin and crypto's opportunity
particularly for finance and it's going
to it's going to impact it you know i
keep on telling people and they don't
fully understand it with defy that when
you own crypto you become your own
personal banker
you you get to borrow against your
your bitcoin or your ethereum
faster quicker better than any way
you've ever been able to borrow before
i
have decent amount of money in the bank
right and i have to go to my banker
and sign forms now it's easier now with
docusign and get their permission to
borrow against my money
at
on on an over collateralized basis so
when i wanted a mortgage for my um well
let's just put aside a mortgage just
excuse me you can do mortgage on the
blockchain now honestly
well exactly right and so the whole
point being when you have uh qualified
digital tradable assets because they can
be traded in real time they're very easy
to collateralize and when you when
they're easy to collateralize and price
then it's really easy to lend against
lesson number six change with the times
with kevin o'leary i work in a very
regulated world i'm an investor in so
many different financial services
companies that are reporting issuers and
so we don't have the luxury of being
offside with regulators not now not ever
and in 2017 when we were talking about
those epic moments and it's true because
i get those things shoved in my face
every day but by but i point out that
when things change i change
that's when i took my first bitcoin
ethereum positions in 2017. obviously
i've done very well with those but
recently after the regulators in
switzerland france germany australia
england japan canada all started to
change their stance on crypto it allowed
me to start to allocate to it in a
compliant way and that's really what got
me going obviously this is an asset
class that's here to stay it's still
going through a very nascent phase i'll
be putting a lot more into it as time
changes and still the regulator's not
100 on board we all know that but things
are getting better not just domestically
but internationally and so i'm an
international investor and in many
countries where we're talking about
bitcoin or ethereum or other assets
other other crypto assets tokens and
coins
the regulators opened up and lesson
number seven the last one before some
very special bonus clips is look for
safety with anthony scaramucci we have
had gold come back in vogue if you will
as the debate on inflation continues to
heat up does that form some competition
again for crypto
listen i'm never going to sell short
gold it's got a 5 500 year history
of offering a store of value but like
everything in our society when you get a
technical property
where there's a massive improvement
that has a tendency to eclipse things
and so you know we we had dvd scott and
we moved to netflix and streaming uh the
satoshi nakamoto white paper basically
put us into a new era
and the technical properties associated
with bitcoin are infinitely better than
gold you can move it
costlessly you can store it virtually
costlessly
and it has
this it you know ledger
that is completely missile locked you
know you can't hack it and so with 21
million coins and it's scarcity remember
we only have 65 of the gold mined right
now
the shortage of supply the technical
properties i think it's probably going
to be 10 times better than gold over a
long period of time
but for right now bitcoin is pacing what
people like michael saylor and kathy
wood are predicting that it will do it
will eventually eclipse gold it's about
a 1.2 trillion
market cap today gold's roughly 11. but
i think bitcoin gets there scott the
same way we're using our smartphone
today and not using a rotary phone i
think they can i think gold will be okay
but it's sort of a flat line situation
can it go up modestly yes but i think
bitcoin and you know properties like
ethereum and algorand are going to go up
exponentially
uh just because of the scalability
security issues around them and so yes
can gold go up certainly if you're gonna
have six percent inflation we'll go up
sure uh but i would i would put my money
and i'm encouraging clients to put their
money in bitcoin you know i've been
talking about that for the last year and
i think we're just getting started in
bitcoin so so for me it can go up but
i'm not going to be surprised if bitcoin
goes up at an exponential rate and gold
is going up at a linear one
bitcoin as i've argued in some of my
writing
is more than just an invention
it's actually the discovery of absolute
scarcity and that we have
unveiled a property of money that we
will only discover once
um and it's
got really major ramifications for the
world at large
so
with gold for instance
as we've covered it became money because
it was the most relatively scarce
monetary metal right its supply was
hardest to increase over time
however
if we could somehow flip a switch today
and make everyone in the world go out
and start mining gold we could increase
the supply much more quickly we could
you know it's historic inflation rate's
about two percent we could double that
pretty quickly
um
bitcoin
with bitcoin it is not possible so no
matter how much effort
and energy and capital uh and
operational expenditure we pour into the
mining network we cannot deviate from
its fixed and diminishing supply curve
from between now and the last bitcoin
being mined in 2140 because of the
difficulty adjustment it's constantly
it's adapting to human action actually
so the harder we pursue it
the more that it proceeds and then the
less we pursue it the more available it
makes itself
and this is
it's a real major breakthrough because
it's the closest thing
to perfect information we've ever had in
an economy
and perfect information is this
it's a theoretical but unattainable
state of the market where
all market actors have all the relevant
information
uh about everything so that they can
compete as efficiently as possible and
in the state in a state of pure
information we have i'm sorry perfect
information we have perfect competition
and in perfect competition we maximize
wealth generation
so we're competing
as freely as possible from
coercive and violent impediments and so
i think bitcoin in that sense
is going to pull the
world closer to a state
a per of perfect competition than we've
ever been before
which would increase wealth degeneration
to an extent we've never seen before
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want a deeper dive into bitcoin check
the video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there much much more
valuable than it is today
do we get institutions to adopt then you
know kind of developing nations and then
there's a default and there's an
inflection point like how do you think
we sequentially get there what does that
like order of operations almost look
like